[Music]
okay guys so some key some key terms in
the phone phones and games this is
probably the most basic fun and games
that you guys have witnessed probably
played in a lot of your games so who
knows how how is it cold right now the
situation that we have on the board
there you go that position and so
basically the opposition is when we have
a one king standing in front of the
other King and right now it's a kind of
a soup trunk if you heard about that so
it looks one is a position where if you
make some move it's actually not such a
desirable move for you
right so guess what so who knows who
knows what's the result is it white
white is going to win this position was
it gonna end up in a draw and maybe
black is gonna win anybody has any ah
very good day good it was a catch
question ok so right now I think I set
it up for white to move what do you guys
think if it's white to move it is a drop
right everybody agrees if it's white to
move well what if it was black to move
it's a win for white yeah and that's
that's correct as well okay so the
opposition now so for example if it's
white to move and white has to move the
King you can move it to a 5 or c5 then
the best-case scenario is that the the
black king they have to move in front of
the King right and then white will try
to push the pawn back and move the pawn
again so obviously the end goal for
white is to promote the Queen right so
you're gonna push it upon as much as
possible and now come as a key moment
for
left to draw the position right so
blacks so blacks options are between
king c6 king c8 King d8 and even King to
eat
so only one of those options actually
draws the position so you have 25%
chance of guessing here correctly so
anybody knows what's the was the drawing
move King d8 yes very good excellent so
you guys know your basics always move
the king and behind the pawn okay
because I usually actually uses to
studied this way that if your opponent
pushes the pawn with a check that's
supposed to end up in a draw so King d8
and now why doesn't it do wrong here he
has to move the king to d6 in this case
it's a stalemate all right now what's
the difference within the first position
that we have an opposition but if it's a
black to move black is the one who has
to move the King and black has to move
the King either to see 7:07 right so you
can set it up so what happens to black
just moved the King to e7 how does how
does white win here exactly King to c6
okay she's gonna come from the other
side all right now if King is six then
it's an easy win right because I'm just
going to promote check and King c7 going
to promote the Queen but the King goes
to d8
and now came the six very well came the
six and now black has to move his King
King to c8 now he wife has two options
on how to win the easiest option is King
a seven right and then the the idea is
that white wants to defend with his King
all those squares it's an easy pass for
the point right but there's another
option for white and it is actually to
push the pawn on d5 and came to d8 now
again we have a we have an opposition
right the two kings are follow each
other but right now it is why to move
right so is did white made a mistake or
is it still winning still winning right
because so the rule says if the King
goes to the sixth rank then it doesn't
matter whose move it is and white is
winning so for example for example if
it's white to move well if it's back to
move then we'll again we do the same
thing if it's white to move then white
pushes the pawn without a check and
black is the one who isn't do wrong so
King c7 and King to e7 okay very well
very good very good
all right I'm going to going to discuss
something more advanced right now we are
going to move into a queen versus pawn
okay so this is a one of the theoretical
positions right white has a king and a
queen for the purposes of our example
that the king is always going to be far
okay so basically the queen is trying to
fight against the king
and upon so obviously if it's black to
move like is going to promote right the
Queen and most of the Queens end games
they end up in a draw right because just
because there are so many repetitions
and checks so it is why to move here so
think about this position do you guys
think that white is going to win or
black is going to draw this position
okay you can pin the pawn that's correct
but then the King moves with f3 okay
that to me okay so what the things that
white that white wins then okay so let's
see so we had a nice first move Queen to
f3 to pin a good idea to pin the pond so
probably I would have to move my king to
d2 right go into d5 guys agree with that
okay so let's try to check the king and
I can just move it maybe to see 224 okay
KMD to
Queen d4 alright
what has changed
so Queen to e3 attacking my pawn and not
doing any checks so now it forces my
King to go to d1 right so this is one of
the key positions to remember in an
endgame of Queen versus one pawn
okay so principle number one you would
like to get get your Queen as close as
possible to the King and upon okay so
zigzagging sometimes but this is a key
position and now the queen is going to
d3 check so now what happens is that
black isn't zoomed one because if you
move to c1 he loses this pawn on e -
okay and if the King moves to e1 great
yeah that gives us time for the King to
come over now it's gonna take a while
because the King moves again to f2 and
then we have to do it all over again
check and then it come from the other
side basically we have to do it all over
again and then the King comes to d3 and
with the help of the King we're going to
capture this pawn okay very good very
good what about if I just move the pawn
one square to the right looks totally
the same but
it's how to calculate till the end just
just a hunch
what's the result anybody knows draw
okay anybody fully win if I thinks it's
whites gonna win okay white will win all
right we'll fight all right sounds good
so first move first move if wife is
gonna win evil you wanted to check on e4
right all right excellent
so you listen to my previous position
saying that the Queen has to come as
close as possible to the king
all right came to d2 let's say and then
Queen f3 right King II won and we got to
the same key position as we saw before
and now Queen III I check so if the King
moves to d1 then we take the pawn so the
King we force the game to go to f1 all
right so looks like it's all the same
right so now the King had moves to g7
right we bring the king and now came to
g2 so what is the difference
all right way to move and the
suggestions for white
okay Queenie for Chuck kingi one all
right Kim G for so check then we get to
the key position right Queen to f3 King
to g1 now Queen to g3 right so this is
what we were aiming for right so this is
our key position all right so your King
goes to f1 then we can continue bringing
a king but there is one but here yeah
the king can go to each one exactly
okay so the Queen could takes on f -
it's a stalemate all right so the Queen
has to keep checking him and it's a draw
now again obviously it is depending what
the White King is if the White King
would be very very close in the
beginning white would be able to win
probably okay but in this case the king
is very far so the f2 pawn is a draw
right I guess we have two more okay so
King on f1 alrighty so here we have the
the pawn on g2 all right so what do you
think about this position so we again we
move the pawn
go the good process of thinking I like
that stalemate okay so no stalemate here
just saying that has no chance anybody
wants anybody thinks it's a draw no wait
okay and you guys are correct so
actually immediately here why can't play
Queen to f3 and here's our key position
so King to e1 loses upon came to g1 to
bring the king and here if I'm not
mistaken the best move would actually be
king queen to f2
to pin the pond so if the king goes to
HT by the way that's a very very easy
wing right once we bring the Queen
behind the pond okay and if the K into
goes to h1 the king
Queen to h4 they will bring the king in
okay all right very good
and last but not least so this is a win
for white what about this one we have a
pond on the edge of the board and h2
it's white to move let's try to find the
stalemate over here draw a win draw in
draw a bunt row who can give you some
more time yeah so that's that's pretty
much correct so yeah so that's C so
check that some with some checks what's
the best one
okay I'm just gonna zigzag
hopefully nobody's keeping notations
okay so okay we just got to a key
position right Queen to GE check that's
what we need to remember and again if
the King goes to f1 black is just losing
the pawn so the King has to go to h1 now
so this is a weird situation because now
white wants to win the king but he can't
write so because that is going to result
in a stalemate all right so therefore
white actually has to move the Queen
somewhere and the King goes to G - okay
now so there was a good question well
where should a king a B in order to to
win so let's see how do I sell it set
this up okay so what is the idea why is
that why is the King so close is winning
so so yeah so that didn't think so yes
this one correct yeah so this one is
winning for white so the idea is to
bring the king of wonder the King to
make an opposition right but not right
now because for example if we just bring
the King in I will bring the king now we
allow the Queen to check the white king
right so this is going to end up in the
draw so first of all we have to bring
the Queen inside so check
check and now when the queen is on the
second-ranked
now we bring the king so the K square is
G 3 Queen and came to G 3
it doesn't it doesn't really matter
where the queen is as long as it's on
the second rank it can be in a - B - D -
so now that has to move to move his
queen somewhere and then it's going to
be made
check and mate okay so so it's a good
question where should the king go so the
key square is G 3 in this position and
so the King has to be two squares away
from the from that square so I assume
it's going to be all of that you can be
on d4 from this side all right let's
check ok would you bet your life on it
good choice
okay so came to d4 so okay so why to
move you're saying king to e3 well
actually King Utley will win Kenny will
win
well yeah but we all were up too close
so I guess the question be what king the
King on e4
that's not winning so here here okay so
what do we have we had this this and
this the box without the square and if
it's on d1 d1 okay yeah that looks
correct
any questions about this endgame well
this endgame is actually useful to know
if you on both sides right if you're the
queen side of the pond side it's pretty
useful to know yeah if you queen then
you made enough to there oh good
question if the King moves
King - II - yeah I think that the lots
of options I would put him in a zoo
swung so I want to get this position but
it's black to move how do we do that you
can try to triangulation yeah King to
itto
yeah that's great so I was just thinking
just to move the Queen to b2 or
something and then forces a black to
move the King
all right good job guys good job okay
next one we're gonna have a puzzle on
some principle let's see who can solve
that one I'm going to add some more
pawns we had only one point this time
okay so why to move the White King to
cut off the blacking well you just say
maybe to put the king somewhere and here
so how do we how do we solve those those
puzzles
yeah that that's easy when he shows it
to you okay so um tip number one is what
I usually tell my students is to come up
with a candidate moves okay it's just
like in chess we cannot analyze all the
moves right so what kind of candidate
moves do we have here so the first one
and everybody saw that is going to be a
four right any other candidate moves a
three yeah but probably not well at all
I'm not going to analyze it a three but
you actually said key to e1 right
okay so K King e1 makes some sense right
to try and to cut the blacks King okay
and any other moves d5 you're gonna give
you up this pawn no okay so we have
three moves okay so how do we decide now
there's another tip I like to say is we
can use the power of elimination so we
eliminate those choices okay it works
very well in M games but it also works
very well in the middle games okay if
this one is better this one is bad then
we are left without the one one choice
okay so the first thing that we like to
do is to promote to a queen right we
have this passed pawn on a four so
obviously we would calculate a four
first now why doesn't this move work
right so how do we know that kind of
thing okay yeah so okay great so I mean
here we have another great tip for the
end games which we call the role of the
square okay so how do we know if the
King is that if the black king is in
time to catch the white pawn and here it
is so we have to go diagonally all the
way till then we're going to create the
square so basically if the key if the
black King can get anywhere inside the
square it's on time to capture the pawn
and right now he can so came to e4 now
after he captures the pawn black is
going to end up with two pawns
it's going to win the game okay yeah so
a foe is wrong right so let's try King
to e1 all right well in this case I
assume that black would play the same
thing right so King to e4 yeah let's say
came to d2 now yeah after he takes this
pawn on d4 the game is pretty much over
because these two pawns the past
protected pawns and white will yeah
they're untouchable exactly there's a
shield so blacks idea black's pawn is
very simple to come in here
stop this pawn take this pawn while
those put points out defended okay so
exactly so we know it's not King 2e1
right so d5 excellent excellent proof so
why is it what is the idea behind d5 so
obviously d5 exactly very good
so d5 pop the poem has to take the pawn
otherwise I'm going to promote and the
idea is correct so now it seems that the
king is in the in the square he can get
into the square but then he gets blocked
by his own piece okay now it's not over
yet so black and try to win d4 a 5 it
looks like black is the one who is going
to come out first and check with us with
the rook so it's a black to move a black
coming to d3 so we see that that we are
going to be checkmated and again we use
the power of elimination right we have a
6 as a candidate move but there's
another movie can play yes and now King
King you won and now the King stabs the
spawn because it came to e3 thinking to
d1
and that's it the the the our pond is
too far away so the black King cannot
capture it to place d2 then we just
promote promote the pond and so on f5 is
too slow
and we can just probably go to f/8 just
to stop him okay
so this is a nice this is a nice tube
this is another thing I wanted to show
you guys the rule of the square okay so
remember now the role of the square is a
mirror by the way I forgot to mention
that in that endgame of the Queen and a
pawn it's a mirror right so if it was
winning drawing winning drawing it's
also on the other side is the same thing
right so if you guys remember the 'i to
pawn was win so the d2 pond is going to
be a winner
so the sea and f2 will draw the G and
the B ponds were winning and H and a
draws yeah so the the
the other and game she looked at the
Queen versus the pawn and the King was
far so it's a mirror right so we looked
only on the right side but on the left
side is the same thing yeah I usually
remember that the on the edges this is
draw and then the knight move I remember
that it's a drop but yeah so in the for
example in our case when we have the
role of the square it's the same thing
so there is a mirror let me show it a
little quick okay so that's a it's black
to move and he can catch the pawn
because that's his square right so we go
diagonally first and so black isn't time
to catch the pawn but also it works on
the other side so obviously if black
would be anywhere on this side on the
right side as well okay I just did I
cannot do it at the square as much no
space for the square on the square
okay so we learn some of the some of the
basic principles in the pawns endgame I
would I wanted to add some some extra
pieces to our end game and now to
actually to cover not such a popular
topic but this one is going to be for
under promotion so usually when we
promote a pond we promoted to a queen
yeah
so in this case this is a puzzle looks
like white is losing because there's a
piece down for two points but actually
why it has a nice combination of how to
to get a winning position it's not a
mate but he gets a winning position okay
so we we can okay let's look at this
variation Queen takes real okay check
okay nice fork kind of mini and the
promotion okay so and now it's white to
move by it looks like the pond is
successfully going to stop the pawns and
more importantly the yeah the pawn is on
the right color of the bishop so if we
have dark square we have this dark
square bishop then he's able to do win
if it will be on white squares for
example here and probably if it was it
was white a move that he would be able
to get into the square yeah so
unfortunately this does not work but
good try good try
I like that idea
okay one buttons mate so probably like
and defend somehow maybe take on b7
yeah that's true
probably do the Queen oh yeah very good
that's our I can't take very good so if
the Queen takes I'm losing this district
on a seven they take their queen okay
you got me
I guess I have to play Bishop F - yeah
defense yeah
so here probably can they can defend
right all right so what are we looking
at
for when we look at puzzles anybody
knows
so yes so let's let's think about our
candidate moves we said Queen d8 we said
we said the rook a 1 now usually when
you get a puzzle like this with a lot of
action you want to look for action moves
right an action of the word and threats
very good and you have to look for those
in that order order okay so we went to
check so we looked at the 1 capsule and
check which is was great did not work we
looked at root k1 which was a threat it
was number 3 but then maybe we can we
skipped some of the checks of the other
checks oh captures okay yes all right so
let's look at this move rope to see a
check
okay so probably the rook is going to
take very good
now the key move Queen takes a seven
teamwork team takes on a seven night I
always play on chess dot-com and I play
some some blitz games and board games
and I always play move and I also
promote the Queen they have an option to
promote automatically to a queen and so
when I get to those positions I never
know how how do I promote to a knight so
something that's something else yeah I I
have no I still have no idea okay so why
to move a last puzzle for that subject
for the subject of under promotion as
you can see white is a rogue down but he
has two pawns a very strong component a
six so this is white to move
uh-huh very good so the only move right
we have a candidate moves the only check
move otherwise is compiled be going to
either take the point somehow keep
checking us so neither five was played
in the game and black played King to f6
all right so if you push the pawn I can
just take and if you queen then the
checkmate well again if you're confusing
yourself yes but we don't have any other
checks right and I don't see any other
threats that we can make other than a
seven so obviously is seven you instinct
did not let you down so he said a seven
is the correct move right and so now if
the King takes on their five we can just
promote to a queen or take the knight so
the question is what happens if the
Bishop takes Knight on their files
sorry Angie yeah
yeah that's true yeah so if I promote a
queen then black can check made me on h2
here okay so yeah that's correct so I
can't promote right because of the check
checkmate
then yes we have to get the King out of
the opposition and so now he has to move
I guess yeah check we have to check
actually because this doesn't work it
should be four
always look for those action wolves okay
so yeah that's correct so II seven
Bishop takes a five and now he ate
checkmate
you don't see those a lot so they're
taking away from him though all of the
squares okay
this is not such an easy position as you
can see you're going to play white again
White has a bishop for two pawns but it
looks like he's going to lose the bishop
so think about this position it is white
white to move draw maybe let them try it
as well okay let's let's eliminate some
moves right so what kind of candidate
moves do we have Bishop g2 a yes okay
anything else King III and g6 okay so we
have those two moves now just sixth we
already discussed before Rainie probably
can take and yeah you can save your
bishop but I I'm really scared of those
pawns so the idea for black even if I
don't win with black the ideas just to
exchange this pawn on h2 so I'm going to
bring one of the pawns to f4 take the
King back and then push all this
de-spawn all the way down and he might
even win yeah because we have another
pawn on h4 so g6 it's not bishop to g3
is not working because of f4
okay so last option that we got left is
king - III a bit of a whip would move
okay so how big the king will take the
bishop okay so what now now you already
have a draw right so if you play King to
f4 that's what we're going to be ending
in trouble because of f6 so that's good
oh yeah you can already make a draw g6
okay yeah but check
so what's the idea of this of this check
if the King takes the pawn I take the
pawn and now he's in Subang right
because here we have the opposition once
the King moves somewhere the King
escapes the king can go to g5 exactly f4
but where should the King go after
that's correct
good f3 not to allow black any counter
chances right so yeah so take the pawn
now again we have only one move because
if we do any other move besides taking
the pawn the king is going and go out to
g5 so King takes an f4
yeah g5 check
so King at 5:00 o king of three
okay so we have only two options right
so we can't go to Eve to any anything on
the e-file because we let the King out
all right so choices would be the Queen
f3 + f5 so let's just try one of them so
King of five black has to play again g4
looks like black is winning because
almost he's gonna play g3 and then
exchange and get the H pawn for free but
black white has only one chance to stop
this pawn and this is by playing King to
f4 and you have to push it three
it's a mate from the other side the King
can also go to f3 so there is no
difference in to f3 you keep the king
from coming out from G for a king to f4
checkmate
yes that's very difficult to see
actually from this for the first
position but again it would the way to
solve it especially when you are down on
time is the process of elimination
komodo come up with those candidate
moves that you need to pick from and
then see ty start to eliminate those
okay guys any questions about porn end
games so anything we discuss today all
right well thank you so much for joining
and I always give I will say that the
most of the work if you want to improve
in chess is done at home and I know that
you guys playing line you're practicing
a lot so that's why I don't want you to
need to be bored so I have so few puzzle
pages for you
[Music]
you
[Music]